bonsoir thomas un week-end donc très
meurtrier qui vient alimenter des
statistiques alarmantes
oui c'est malheureusement assez habituel
qu'il y ait une hausse du nombre de
victimes par arme à feu le week-end de
la fête nationale américaine mais c'est
vrai que cette année les statistiques
sont particulièrement alarmante
particulièrement tragique avec une
recrudescence des tirs par arme à feu
alors il ya un site qui s'appelle gun
violens arxiv qui tente de recenser le
nombre de tirs par arme à feu le nombre
de victimes pour l'ensemble de ce
week-end selon leurs estimations qui
sont encore provisoires
au moins 150 personnes sont décédées
lors de 400 fusillade qui a eu lieu rien
que ce week-end sur l'ensemble du
territoire américain
vous est pris l'exemple de deux villes
qui ont été particulièrement touchés
d'abord la ville de philadelphie qui
avait un rassemblement une foule qui
était massée pour observer les feux
d'artifices pour cette fête nationale
américaine
à ce moment là un tireur ou plusieurs
tireurs on ne sait pas encore tout à
fait les circonstances de cet acte ils
ont tiré donc sans munitions en
direction de cette foule ça a tué deux
jeunes personnes deux jeunes hommes et
une fille de 16 ans a été sérieusement
blessée dans la ville de cela delphi
depuis le début de l'année on est déjà à
281 homicide
c'est une augmentation de 37% par
rapport à l'année 2020 une année 2020
qui était déjà record pour justement le
nombre d'homicides dans la ville autre
exemple vous avez déjà un petit peu
parlé c'est la ville de chicago 104
personnes ont été victimes de tirs par
arme à feu ce week end
dix neuf personnes au moins sont décédés
13 enfants ont été blessés et là encore
dans cette ville les statistiques sont
assez alarmante puisque depuis le début
de l'année on est déjà à 2000 fusillade
dans la ville de chicago est thomas
quelle est la position du gouvernement
américain sur ce sujet
il n'y a pas eu de réaction officielle
pour le moment de la part des autorités
que ce soit de joe biden ou de sa porte
parole qui s'est exprimé dans le courant
de la journée pour l'instant pas de
prise de parole publique sur ce sujet
mais on sait que joe biden a fait de la
lutte contre la circulation des armes à
feu un des
des priorités de son mandat il a annoncé
un plan le 24 juin dernier pour tenter
d'une part de limiter le type d'armes
qui peut être acheté aussi pour
renforcer le contrôle du profil des
potentiels acheteurs d'armes à feu et
puis il veut aussi s'attaquer au marché
parallèle il a annoncé le déploiement de
cinq unités spéciales dans cinq villes
des états unis dont la ville de chicago
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que
malgré ces chiffres très important de
victimes par le feu dans la ville de
chicago
on ne peut pas dans cette ville acheter
une arme dans un magasin il s'agit donc
essentiellement d'armes issues du marché
parallèle alors ce plan de joe biden se
heurte au blocage parlementaire de la
part des élus d'opposition les élus
républicains examen que vous savez le
fameux second amendement de la
constitution américaine qui stipule que
les américains ont le droit de porter
une arme
et puis pour les élus républicains la
cause du nombre de cette augmentation du
nombre de victimes par arme à feu et
finalement le laxisme d'un certain
nombre d'élus démocrates
évidemment la maire de chicago qui est
donc une mère démocrate est très
régulièrement la victime de critiques de
la part des élus républicains qui
accusent notamment vous savez ce
mouvement qui lors des manifestations
qui ont eu lieu l'an passé appelé à
démanteler une partie de la police en
coupant un certain nombre de
financements alors s'il n'ya pas
d'entendre sur les causes de cette
augmentation du nombre d'homicides en
tout cas il ya un constat c'est que
c'est en nette augmentation 2020 a été
une année record par rapport au nombre
de victimes par arme à feu joe biden
parle même d'une épidémie de violence
avec ses armes dont qui circulent aux
états unis merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington